hello everyone so
my name is robert pilaf
i'm a senior post-doctoral fellow
in the lab of um professor vero bakland
at the k11 in belgium and so
my work in the labs work has been
focused on
the role of apple cinnaline strains and
synclenopathies
and so we've been doing this work over
the last almost 10 years now
and so i'll be talking about the
relevance and the importance of
cyanocleaning strains in these
diseases
i also noticed that there are two
other talks that also focus on the topic
of alpha cynuclean and parkinson's
disease so
hopefully this talk also supplement
those other
presentations as well
so as a quick overview here so what i
would just like to discuss is first of
all the synucleinopathy so just
introduce these diseases
and then tell you why we think
alpha-sinuclean strains are
important and relevant to these diseases
then talk about cyanuclean strains and
some of the experimental models and
the experimental work that we have done
and then also finally
some words and some slides on how we
believe the environment more
specifically the cellular environment
can also impact strain behavior
and the development of these
diseases
so
the innopathies is is a large and also
very heterogeneous group of brain
disorders some nerve diseases and so it
includes
multiple system atrophy msa dementia
with lewy bodies or dlb and parkinson's
disease or pd
and what all of these diseases have in
common is that
when you look in the brain and the
central nervous system and even outside
of the central nervous system
is that in
the brain of these people you'll find um
inclusions or aggregates of the protein
alpha cynuclein
and so this is really a key pathological
feature that all of these diseases share
and so
this reflects also this umbrella term
synonymous
um reflecting the presence and probably
also the importance of alpha-synuclein
aggregation and pathology
in these diseases
so alpha-synuclein
comes in many forms and shapes and
originally was was identified and
initially characterized in in
parkinson's disease where it was found
to be
a key hispathological substrate in the
disease
and so
when people were examining for instance
substantial which is a region that is
heavily affected in parkinson's disease
where there's
also cell death
you find these protein deposits
inclusions within
dopaminergic cells
and so these inclusions were then named
after uh the person who initially
described in friedrich louis and so then
they were called lewy bodies so again
stressing the importance of
alpha-synuclein protein here
so then when you look um in more detail
you know into these inclusions you know
inside of these flowy bodies so here you
can actually see a cross-section of how
that looks like you can see a cell here
in panel a and panel b and c you can see
higher magnifications of that
inclusion and you can see around like a
big inclusion lots of
membranous and
lipid accumulations or reflecting
organelles and mitochondria that are
accumulating around
what is a rich filamentous core of
protein
deposits
and you can actually for instance also
purify or isolate
the protein from these deposits and you
will see that you'll end up with these
long
insoluble filaments fibrils
that are so typical and characteristic
of of the disease so these are the
cyanuclean fibrils
that will have
an important role in the disease process
so
all of these diseases actually share
synuclein aggregation as a main core
feature but there are also many
differences not only in the clinical
picture but also on the cellular level
for instance in parkinson's disease and
dementia with lewy bodies
you'll find these synuclein inclusions
within
neurons
but then if you look at multiple system
atrophy
you won't find these same type of you
know these typical inclusions in neurons
but instead you'll find them in glial
cytoplasmic inclusions so you'll find
them in the oligodendrocytes
again in the brain uh and even outside
the brains the peripheral nervous system
of people with multiple system atrophy
and this for multiple system atrophy
again is truly a core feature
so the inclusion of cynucline
or the formation of synuclein aggregates
within um oligodendrocytes
and so because of this parkinson's
disease and also dimensional lewy bodies
are
primary
neuropathies so
synuclein aggregation and pathology
in neurons resulting in
dysfunctional neurons and eventually
even neuronal cell death
so there you have a primary neuropathy
whereas multiple system atrophy where
you have the other condendra sites being
affected
we more talk about a primary oligarchs
in room gliopathy
where there's significant myelin loss
then
resulting in a loss of traffic support
loss of metabolic support
and with that also
a loss of neuronal health and neuronal
cell death
these oligodendrocytes actually survive
and so you'll find lots of these
inclusions these clyocytoplastic
inclusions with synuclein
aggregation and so it's really the
demyelination and the
neuronal laws that again is is a
driving factor in the disease process of
multiple system atrophy
so parkinson's disease is um
by far the most common form of the
synucleinopathies um one in 100 people
above the age of 65 will have pde
for dlb it's it's it's much less uh
it's it's not so well known what you
know what the exact prevalence is of the
dimension with lewy bodies there are
some estimates but
it is considered to be less prevalent as
parkinson's disease and msa is is a rare
disease it only occurs in one in 25 000
people
but it's also actually the most
aggressive form of all cineclinopathies
so similarities but also differences in
in the cellular level and then when we
look at clinical features uh symptoms
and here i'm just going to focus on
parkinson's and multiple system atrophy
um you'll also see some striking
differences between these diseases
so here you have some of the core
features of parkinson's disease and
you can also map these here on the
timeline
and what you'll see is that
so for parkinson's disease here at the
time of diagnosis people will present
with the more typical
motor symptoms
neurology features
that are so characteristic of
parkinson's disease but even long before
this you will see that people have
um a multitude of
symptoms that mostly associated with um
peripheral symptoms such as constipation
uh rem sleep behavior disorder is
actually an important uh pro dormal
symptom in parkinson's disease hypothmia
uh but even depression and then once the
disease advances you'll have
more symptoms um adding on to the
earlier features
and
so that can also be mapped in terms of a
spatial tempo temporal pattern
and um so normally i added an animation
here but
just because of a technical glitch this
this is not going to work but
what was supposed to show here is that
these cyanuclean protein inclusions
can
can be found in different stages
that correspond actually quite nicely
with the
pathology and
the symptoms that people would exhibit
for instance um
in terms of we're going to call the
branch hypothesis or the body first
hypothesis you could find these protein
inclusions for instance first in the gut
or in other you know peripheral areas
and then they would spread through
either the vagal nerve or even
sympathetic innervation through the
to the brain stem and then cause
pathology
um and
spread the pathology along anatomically
connected regions
next to that there is now also the idea
that there is a body first
spatial
temporal pattern where the pathology
then initially originates in the nose or
in the limbic system and then spreads in
the opposite direction resulting in
an opposite staging scheme so again
synuclein pathology correlating with the
symptoms that people would exist or
the regions associated with those
symptoms
in case of multiple system atrophy
you immediately see that this disease
has
[Music]
an incredible
range of symptoms and also here we can
map all of these symptoms to a timeline
what you can see here is that the
timeline first of all is much shorter so
instead of you know going up to 10 20
years people with multiple systematic
usually live about six to nine years
with the disease even before diagnosis
you can see that there are many actually
very many pre-motor symptoms that
characterize the disease
for msa typically people sometimes also
develop
urogenital
dysfunction so there's energy erectile
dysfunction
urinary incontinence and so forth also
strikingly and interestingly in this
diseases is the
is the
the prominent
infections that people will have and
recurrent infections that they have such
as for instance utis
autonomic dysfunction is also really
prominent here again rem sleep behavior
disorder is also
something that is that appears to be
important in the disease process and
then again later on you'll have more and
more symptoms that
that will be added on
while when the disease progresses
for multiple system atrophy there isn't
as
a typical spatial temporal pattern that
for instance
[Music]
would correlate synuclein pathology with
clinical symptoms or
pathology
per se
but
what we do know for multiple system
atrophy is that there are two
forms or two variants of the disease
where in one case
for one variant the cerebellar functions
will dominate and in case of the
parkinsonian
variant there are more parkinsonian
symptoms that dominate and in the end
people will usually
converge and symptoms will converge and
people will develop a full-blown msa
phenotype
but so the synuclein pathology here with
the glial cytoplasmic inclusions hasn't
been
mapped to the same extent as for
instance in the case of parkinson's
disease so we don't really have good
information on
on how you know the synuclein
aggregation and synuclein pathology
correlates with the disease process
so
so that was the introduction to cynic
syndicalenopathies and so
many you know quite some time ago um our
labs started investigating
um
why there is only
or why there seems to be one molecular
event
in a large group of diseases because
we found it quite odd that you have this
one protein alpha cynuclein
and this protein being involved in so
many different
diseases but still you would have
diseases with such different
phenotypes or such different clinical
pictures
so we couldn't really
understand
how this one protein is involved in all
of these diseases and then people
developing such you know striking
different diseases
and the idea that we then had at the
time
is that synuclein itself
might aggregate differently and form
different types of structures so the
assembly into these filaments or the
assembly into these fibrils
would then be different resulting in
what we didn't call different types of
strains
so reflecting the structural
confirmation of these protein aggregates
and we thought that if it is possible to
for instance produce different types of
aggregates
would it be possible that these
different types of actives then would
have different functions or different
biological roles or different
pathologies and with that potentially
cause let's say different diseases or
different phenotypes
and so we started testing this and we
started working with
the lab of professor milky
and
in his lab was luke
who was at the time and generating
different types of alpha-synuclein
fibrils
and here in the left side of the left
picture you can see
ribbon type fibrils um which are you
know aggregates or fibrils of
alpha-sinuclean that have this twisted
conformation and because they look like
you know twisted ribbons we call them
ribbons and then in the right panel the
right side of the
of the picture you can see just the more
conventional normal type of fibrils
that are just rot shaped and and and
cylindrical
and so
then we started experimenting with these
two well-defined
synuclein fibrils or sunuclean strains
and then we wondered if we you know
expose these and inject these in
the rat substance in agra in an animal
model that we had available at the time
would it be possible that these fibrils
then would cause or trigger a phenotype
that would reflect their
structure
and so once we started doing that we
we noticed that a need upon injection of
these different strains the ribbons and
the fibrils that both strains were
causing very distinctive phenotypes for
instance here what is shown is just the
histopathology of these fibrils when
injected into the substance in niagara
with ribbons causing
much more phosphorylated alpha-synuclein
inclusions which is the pathological
marker that is used to detect these type
of inclusions so fossil serene 129
the post-translational modification of
alzheimer's found in deposited
inclusion
and so you can see for ribbons
that ribbons cause much a much higher
degree of inclusions and include
information in vivo in the brain of
these rats injected with fibrils
then in contrast to this when looking at
neurotoxicity
interestingly then we saw that these
fibrils were actually causing
more neurotoxicity compared to the
ribbons so even though these ribbons
were associated with
inclusion and inclusion formation it was
actually the fibrils that were causing
more toxicity and cell death
and also finally interesting for this
part what we found is that upon
injection of these ribbons in our model
that was expressing human
alpha-synuclein in our animal model we
found that these certains were also
causing
glial cytoplasmic inclusions so
typically inclusions that you would
observe in people with a multiple system
atrophy and oligonembrocytes
whereas for virals we could not see this
so with those experiments i think we
showed
that
there is a
relationship between the structure of
a fibril or strain and the phenotype and
the pathology that will develop
so a strain a for instance then will
cause phenotype a and strain b will
cause phenotyping so that's that's
actually the
um
i say the the
the importance or the relevance of those
strains in that particular animal model
so the next we asked is it possible to
do this with more let's say relevant
brain material because these were
synthetic fibrils that were assembled in
random buffer conditions
um so one was assembled in
low salt conditions whereas that whereas
the other strain was assembled in in
physiological uh physiological buffer
conditions
so next we wondered is it possible for
instance to isolate these strains from
patient brain and then again inject them
into our animal models and so what we
did is we isolated synuclein aggregates
from pd brain dlb and msa brain
then we incubated them just with cinder
clean monomers
we fractionated them by sonication
and then
by templating the fractionated
sonicated seeds of those isolated
fibrils with a
new new monomers um we were amplifying
the material and by you know doing this
several times by amplifying so
sonicating amplifying and so forth
you end up with a pure homogeneous
material that then again can be injected
into animal models and then can be
studied
and so we did that for um
all of the three
main cinnalinopathy so here we have four
parkinson's disease patients um here six
msa patients and again four dlp patients
here you can see the fireballs and the
ribbons again
and so by amplifying so purifying and
amplifying those strains
we were now able to assess
whether these fibrils isolated from
human brain would
behave the same way so and print their
structural features into the environment
to which they are exposed and
potentially cause different types of
pathologies
so then again by injecting all of these
strains into a rat substantia [ __ ] we
found that the
pd strains and the msa strains both
caused not only nerve toxicity but also
severe behavioral deficits so here you
see the the quantifications for neuronal
cell laws or dopaminergic excellence in
the substantia [ __ ]
and here you can see some representative
images of the [ __ ]
being gone here in case for the msa
condition pd and then the control on dlv
conditions next to that
but what also stood out here is that in
case of the msa strains or the msa
fibrils that these msa fibrils cast much
more
inclusions
again assessed by phosphorylated serine
129
we found that when injected in the
substantia [ __ ] these inclusions would
spread
more throughout the brain but also you
would see much more of the inclusions
when the animals were injected with msa
strains so again comparing them with the
pd control and
the dlp material
we also saw the same
the immune response so looking at
microglial activation
mhse1 staining for instance here but
also other markers for
lymphocytes cd4 markers um
a peripheral immune infiltration and so
forth we noticed that in case again for
the msa strains there was much more
inflammation
after these strains were injected into
our animal models
so in conclusion for the strains what we
found is that the nuclear strains can
cause unique pathologies in multiple
models so we tested this in various
cellular models as well as well as in
our animal models these trains and also
amplicate and replicate in a strain
dependent manner so you can isolate them
back again from the brain and then what
you'll see is that they'll have
replicated and amplified also in a
strain dependent manner
and also finally it's not only the work
with the synthetic strains where we were
able to show this but also the work with
the patient derived strains from um
um some relevant uh patient-derived
material where we found that again
cynically fibrils and these different
alpha centroclean strains can dictate
different disease characteristics
and then just finally to build on those
findings we've now been exploring what
the
role is of the cellular environment on
strain
behavior and so i just have a couple of
more slides
um
on that as well
so
as i mentioned earlier
there is an interesting solar tropism
when it comes to
these different pathologies so in case
of multiple system atrophy you will find
gliocytoplasmic inclusions and
accumulation of alpha-synuclein within
all like vendor sites whereas in
parkinson's and dlb these inclusions
will form in neurons
now what is a bit odd is that
when we take
the strains derived from pd brain or
strains derived from msda and inject
them in our
rodent model
we find that after
incubation and amplification and the
pathology that they cause that in case
of the pd string you'll find a pd-like
phenotype but in case of the msa strains
you'll find a sort of mixed phenotype
where the pathology actually propagates
within neurons instead of the expected
oligodendrocytes so there appears to be
some sort of discrepancy here or
dichotomy between
the cellular environment and
the strain that is amplifying
and
the reason why this is actually came
from a really interesting study by the
group of virginia le
where they incubated different types of
primary cultures with
[Music]
synthetic form synthetic strains but
also patient-derived
fibrils
and so after incubating for instance
these fibrils here in a primary neuronal
culture or in a oleg dendroglial culture
both cultures expressing human alpha
synuclein
they found that after incubation and
amplification of these strains that in
case of the
neurons they would end up with a
slightly modified strain that would
reflect the neuronal culture but then
after incubation
here in the oligodendroglial culture
they would find that the strain would
have
much more modified
much more infectious and much more toxic
suddenly so it seems that an
oligodendroglial
culture or an oligodendroglial
environment is able to
have an effect or modify the
amplification and the propagation of
of finuclean fibers or cyanuclean
assemblies
and so to investigate how this
[Music]
how this really works we also started
working again with the ribbons and the
fibrils shown earlier but instead of
using
a let's say more parkinson
animal model we now switch to a
multiple system atrophy model
so the mice that we used for this
experiment are transgenic uh mice that
express alpha-synuclein under control of
the plp promoter and so by that they
express alpha-synuclein
in oligodendrocytes so now we have an
environment that is prone to develop
multiple system atrophy and so we
wondered is it possible that these
strains can not only
impose or imprint their structural
features and their
their function
within the environment they're exposed
to but also is it possible that they can
develop and contribute to the msa
phenotype
and so after
a period of 11 or 12 months
we then analyzed the
[Music]
substantia [ __ ] stratum and the
different brain areas associated here
um with um
basal ganglia and so what you can see
here for instance immediately if you
look at
panel j or image j here this picture is
that these fibrils cause
tremendous brain atrophy
compared to ribbons where the effect is
is
is even not there
and in any assay that we used any assay
looking at
cell function or cell death we found
that these fibrils were again the most
toxic species causing significant
dopaminergic cell death loss of darp 32
medium spiny neurons in the striatum
laws of total number of neuronal cells
again here in the striatum also
very striking laws of myelin so
demyelination here as well and again
loss of striatal volume and an increase
in ventricular volume so these fibrils
again are
causing very significant neurotoxicity
whereas these ribbons
do this to a much lesser extent
so the next what we wanted to assess
here is how these strains and the
environment then are
you know interacting
and for this we started working with
luminous and conjugated oligophyofemes
or lcos and more specifically we started
working with hfta which is one of the
many lco that are available so these are
developed by the lab peter nilsson and
so we've also been working with teresa
clinks that has been
been very helpful in setting this up
here in our lab and love them
and so these um these lcos are flexible
um fluorescent molecules that can bind
with amyloid uh in case of the hepta
ftaa lco
that can bind with anything that is as
big as
seven monomers anything larger than that
can be bound by by these probes
and so the interesting thing about these
is not that they're just very specific
and sensitive for instance them they're
much more sensitive than for instance
diaflavin but they also have their own
spectral signature so they can bind with
different types of assemblies and
because of the backbone being flexible
they can also bind different types of
assemblies you know and and have a
different spectral signature that will
then translate to the confirmation of
these different types of fibrils so for
instance if you have it bound to ribbon
or fiber you will see a different
spectral signature
and so as a way to set this up in our
lab then i started just stating first
some
msa brain and some control
non-diseased brain
just to double check how you know the
probe would bind with um glials out of
plastic inclusions and to see if we
could actually um use this for our
animal models so on the left you see
staining for phosphorylated alpha
cyanuclean um i'm sorry
yeah staining for phosphorylated alpha
synuclein so in the control sample it's
it's uh it's negative and for here this
person where uh stay into caudate
potamon you can see lots of inclusions
and gliocytoplastic inclusions um uh
indicative of you know cynical
accumulation and also multiple system
atrophy
so then when combining this marker with
uh
the lco probe you can see again that
this is negative in the control
condition but then for the msa condition
you can see that there is a nice
overlapping correlation between the two
markers so
showing that indeed we can use this to
look at the glial cytoplasmic inclusions
in our you know
not only patient samples but also in our
model
so so this is really to illustrate the i
think the real beauty of this this
technique because you can combine this
with other markers so here you can see
olig 2 which is a marker for
oligodendrocytes and with that you can
go looking specifically for inclusions
in oligodendroglial cells
and by doing so then i was able to
determine the
emission spectra here of the probe bound
with aggregates inside oligodendrocytes
and so i did this for all of the
different conditions that we had here so
it's just the transgenic model so these
were animals injected with bsa
then the animals injected with the
ribbons the animals injected with
fibrils and then also the
msa patients
and so what you see is that for all of
these different conditions you will have
different
emission spectra and different
types of spectral signatures
and then this can be quantified and with
these quantifications you can see that
in case of the bsa conditions you have
this
very
variable and heterogeneous folding
landscape so you can see the the data
points really stretched out along the
the y um
the the y axis again indicating that
there are many different types of
conformations in this model and also
that there isn't one particular let's
say dominant confirmation in the
transgenic model itself
but then when you for instance inject
the fireballs you can see a shift in the
conformational
state of these oligonegle inclusions
and even more so when you look at the
ribbons you can see that these ribbons
are
again in printing their structural state
within the cellular milia or solar
environment
where the propagation is happening and
also that it is reflecting more that of
the multiple system atrophy
cases
so i'm just going to skip these couple
of slides and just go directly to the
conclusions because i'm running out of
time here
and so with that i think
i was able to show
that there is an important
correlation or an important relationship
between
strains and the environment
so
oligodendrocytes can clearly impact
strain propagation
where the environment is really a
facilitator
for in case of multiple systematic in a
phenotype that develops here
with providing the soluble cynucline or
the sinuclean monomer for these strains
to amplify so the phenotype here in this
case is actually determined by the
strain and the cellular milia
and so by seeding in our msa model with
different types of fiber fibrils we are
able to more more closely develop
an msa model and
again the
the msa phenotype
so that just leaves me with the last
slide here which are the
acknowledgements of course for the lab
and love and the lab of professor vader
bakland and everybody who contributed to
this work also ronald melke who's been
really instrumental in all this work
peter nilsson also as well here and
nadia stefanova for
uh her help with the transgenic msa
model
and of course
everybody here attending this
presentation so thank you for it for
your attention